all right so that was the first one
area of these uh two figures combined
together within this rectangle let's
have a go at the next one
now if you've uh been paying attention
to the previous problem you already know
what piece of mass is going to be
involved here but in case you're
watching this one for the first time
you're like uh we're like what's going
on here what's what's this problem to do
with right I want you to pause and have
a think uh if you know that uh you've
got a rectangle here a b c d
and you've got some point in the middle
that has been chosen such that the
lengths from the corners are seven five
and eight respectively what is the
length to this final corner here how can
we work out what uh the value of c p is
well if you've paused the video then how
to go yourself I'm about to spoil it so
get ready for yourself
to solve this problem what I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a series of
right angle triangles that are going to
allow me to relate the 7 and the five
and eight number one with each other and
number two with the unknown length that
I'm after okay
so uh maybe for starters I'll call that
unknown length x and then I'll also
notice that if I draw a bunch of lines
that are perpendicular and parallel to
the sides that go through P that's going
to be very useful for me because it
creates all those right angle triangles
that I was after right so for example
if I draw a leg like so and then I'm
also going to draw one across oh I think
I missed but that's okay we can
fix it up
there we go
okay what I have created is a series of
right angled triangles thing I can
relate to each other using say for
example if I put some names on these so
if I say okay let's call this I've
already got Capital A's for the the
vertices for the corners so I'll call
this little a here
it's going to go across from here to
here I'll call this little b
from here to here and then I need some
vertical length so let's call this one
here
C and then I'll call this one here D now
a b c and d they all appear in lots of
different places so you can see I'm
going to get some relationships here if
I can identify where the appropriate
right angle triangles are so let's
actually see if we can draw some of
these in so I'm going to use let's go
with this color shall we
let's draw
a triangle in there
and let me make that a little easier for
you to see so I'll make that smaller I
make this field there we go
I can make that just a little bit better
I think I'll need to zoom in though
let's try that get that right in that
corner
and same for this one okay I'm satisfied
with that all right so having a look at
this first right angle triangle here you
can see I've got an unknown here a and
unknown here C but the hypotenuse is
seven right so I can say off of that a
squared plus c squared equals 7 squared
okay so far so good
now if you have a look over to the other
side uh this this purple triangle is not
the only one that C appears in right so
if I just copy this across and let's
move this over here I will just choose a
different color so it's a bit easier for
you to distinguish
not the outside but the actual filling
there we go that's a bit better
so you can see here
I don't have a squared and c squared
I've got B squared and c squared so if I
combine those two together B squared
plus c squared equals 5 squared now I've
got one last length to actually use it's
that eight that hasn't actually been um
used up yet so if I copy this down to
here
what have I got here so
again let's choose another color for
that
that'll do for the outside there we go
okay so you can see here I have D is my
vertical length there and I also have by
virtue of the opposite size being equal
to each other I've got an A down here as
well so that gives me a squared
plus D Squared is equal to 8 squared
okay so I've got three equations here
that use the 7 5 and the eight and then
lastly I've got this sort of unknown
triangle here I don't know anything here
right at least no values so I've got the
B which you saw just like with the a
it's it's opposite to this length up
here so I've got if I just for good
measure since I did it for all the other
ones might as well do it for this one
too
let's move this across this way I wonder
how it will look if I just do that now
let's do the outside as well because I'm
picky like that all right uh yeah I'm
satisfied now if you have a look at this
blue triangle I again have the shorter
sides in terms of B's and D's and then
the hypotenuse is the part that I want
right so I can say B squared
plus d squared equals x squared all
right so you can see here if I if I just
highlight this right and I used this
color over here this is the uh this is
the equation which I'm going to kind of
focus on right because it has the X in
it that I'm after but what it it has
that I don't want is is this being this
neat because I don't know what they are
right however I do notice B and D appear
in these other equations so if I were to
name these right let's call these
equations one two and three you can see
that the B squared and the D Squared
that I want they appear in equations two
and three but to invoke equations two
and three you then sort of include these
problems right you've got c squared and
a squared which you don't want
but you're probably seeing where this is
going right I can use equation one which
has just a squared and c squared in it
to get rid of the a squared and c
squared that I don't want from equations
two and three so I guess the way that I
would write this is I would say taking
all of these right I would say if you
add equations two and three you will get
the B squared and D Squared that you
want but you'll get the a squared and c
squared that you don't want so therefore
I'm going to subtract the first equation
which will eliminate those out and then
of course whatever's happening on the
right hand side we can then deal with
that so what am I going to get well
as we mentioned you'll get the B squared
and the D Squared the a squared and the
c squared will be removed I mean if you
want in your working you can add and
subtract them but I think we've just
made the algorithm pretty clear
and what do you get on the right hand
side well we get equation 2 gives us 5
squared equation 3 gives us 8 squared
and then the equation 1 gives us 7
squared so I subtracted or rather I've
added and subtracted everything on the
left I've added and subtracted
everything on the right but then I can
say if I call this you know equation 4 I
can say but
from or substituting in might be a
better way to say it
I can substitute that b squared
plus D Squared for x squared so that's
going to give me x squared on the left
hand side that gives me 25 plus 64 take
away 49 and the last time I checked that
was equal to 40. so therefore X is going
to be the square root of 40 because X is
a length so I disregard the negative
so
with the previous problem these right
angled triangles find a way of sneaking
their weight into all kinds of geometry
problems what I like about this one is
that even though there are so many
unknowns like I never found out what a b
c and d were but I didn't need to
because these relationships here from
the right angle triangles I could use to
sort of cancel things out and again not
only did the question not tell you that
hey there's no angle triangles here
you're not necessarily uh see that
Pythagoras is relevant from the from out
the gate you also weren't told that
you'd need to create a system of
simultaneous equations that you would
have to solve but it just emerges from
the problem so this is often the way
right in in real world problems you
don't get told there isn't some heading
at the top saying Pythagoras Theorem or
simultaneous equations and then that
Clues you into the kind of maths that
you need you have to look at the problem
start to do this process of turning the
language or the diagram into
mathematical symbols and then as you
look at the symbols and see how they
relate to each other you start to see oh
this is the maths I'm going to need I
need to I'm going to use algebra I'm
going to need to use sound test
equations and whatever else needs to be
relevant